[ __ ] vraiment fait miroiter des choses
professionnellement pour obtenir des
choses d'elle lui aurait fait miroiter
des choses
donc ça si c'est le cas c'est vraiment
dégueulasse après on apprend aussi faim
on réapprend quelques s'est rendu chez
lui à plusieurs reprises il faudrait
dire que voilà c'est pas parce que
quelqu'un est connu qu'il faut accepter
tout de suite d'aller à son domicile
c'est pas normal d'aller chez quelqu'un
tard le soir juste parce qu'il est connu
donc je pense qu'il faut dire aux
personnes connues et puissante d'arrêter
de se croire tout permis et pour
certains je dis pas que c'est le cas des
bdr mais de se comporter comme des porcs
puisqu'on parle de balançon port et pour
les autres de ne pas accepter d'aller
chez quelqu'un juste parce qu'il est
connu
je vais vous raconter une histoire qui
va vous intéresser qui est folle et
géraldine à vous intéresser
particulièrement parce que vous êtes fan
c'est l'histoire qui concernent novak
djokovic le numéro un mondial du psg
revient de tomber regardez cette
histoire et l'interview exclusive de
natalia skitch une mannequin serbe a été
publié dans un magazine
la jeune femme révèle avoir été
sollicité pour participer à une
opération marque particulièrement
malveillantes dont la cible était novak
djokovic elle dit un homme que je
connaissais et que je croyait jusque-là
sérieux m'a contacté pour un rendez vous
que je pensais professionnel au fil de
notre conversation j'ai vite compris que
quelque chose n'allait pas je pensais
même à une caméra cachée quand il m'a
expliqué que je devais séduire novak
djokovic il m'a dit que je pouvais je
pouvais obtenir 60 mille euros pour cela
est un voyage où je voulais j'ai rigolé
je pensais qu'il allait me dire qu'il
blaguait mais cet homme était très
sérieux rapidement l'objectif immoral
lui étaient présentées elles devaient
tout faire pour charmer novak djokovic
dans le but d'enregistrer une vidéo de
leurs rapports sexuels à son insu la
sextape aurait ensuite été dévoilée au
monde entier pour faire scandale et
porté atteinte à sa réputation au revoir
à sa carrière
je me suis sentie offensée humilié même
il préparer vraiment un plan
machiavélique jeu de vendée novak dans
un endroit intime et toupie mais en
entendant ça j'ai pris mes affaires et
je suis parti j'espère qu'ils ne
trouveront pas une fille qui acceptent
de faire ça c'est quand même incroyable
il va nous sortir que ses environs des
comptes mais les stars internationales
comme novak djokovic n ai marre aussi
qui a eu des histoires comme ça comment
ils font aujourd'hui donc pour pour
aborder une vie sentimentale normalement
ils doivent avoir peur de tout
maintenant avec les réseaux sociaux les
enrichissent comment les captures
d'écran c'est terrible c'est illogique
serré mais dans une certaine presse
anglaise et d'un tabloïd trash anglais
qui faisait ça il sollicitait y paient
des jeunes femmes pour séduire notamment
des footballeurs professionnels unfp où
sont tombés dans le piège
ben oui
et écoutez franchement nous a déjà fait
savoir un casse tête j'ai failli tomber
dans un piège
non c'est pas vrai que c'est vrai pas
vrai j'ai bien fait il ya quelques
années j'ai failli tomber dans un piège
aussi beau que jamais jamais jamais
jamais là j'avais eu une relation avec
quelqu'un mais je peux pas les plus
forts étaient là mon micro effectivement
on devait se retrouver quelque part et
je sais pas j'ai senti j'ai senti le
piège est effectivement il y avait des
paparazzi qui étaient là donc le but
était quoi de me faire prendre en photo
avec la personne et après des bandes me
faire chanter
grâce à dieu je vais pas dans l'empiré